A little piece of the UK in the heart of Berlin's
Kreuzberg district: 'Broken English' has sold
groceries and souvenirs from the island nation
for 24 years.
"This is my final purchase here at 'Broken
English', as this shop will soon close.
There are also Brexit victims in Berlin."
Dale Carr, a native Briton, has spent almost
half her life in this shop.
Now, she's retiring -- but cannot find anyone
who wants to take over the shop.
In this era of Brexit, trying to make a living
selling imported goods from Britain seems
just too risky.
"I am not sure who would take the chance at
the moment.
To find himself in a position, where they
are not able to get hold of the stock that's
required.
There is a possibility of going through Ireland,
that we thought of ourselves, but of course
Ireland has its own issues at the time.
It's just simply not knowing."
Ever since the Brexit referendum two-and-a-half
years ago, Britain's leaving the EU has been
a constant topic of conversation here in Broken
English.
In order to remain EU citizens, many of Dale
Carr's customers have taken on German citizenship
– including the shopkeeper herself.
What is your view on the Brexit?
Dale Carr: "Oh dear...well.
My own personal view, that it is a terrible
mistake.
That the Uk is making.
I simply don´t understand the politics behind
it or what they possibly think what will be
better."
Brexit is to blame for her now giving up.
A clearance sale began this week in Broken
English.
"Bourbon biscuits, John Smith beer, a fancy
gin, baked beans, or Marmite: love 'em or
hate 'em, these goods will no longer be so
easy to find in Berlin.
But this also has to do with a piece of Britons'/British
identity in Berlin."
"This is like home.
You walk in look at the environment here.
It's very nice it's very quaint it's really
England here."
"I think it's a shame I think it's really
sad.
But I guess you can't really help the effects
of this uncertainty makes it really hard for
businesses to carry on.
"Horrible.
I need the tea from here.
I need the sweets from here.
And whenever one of my English friends has
a birthday, I buy presents here."
The greatest present for Dale Carr would be
an 'exit from the Brexit'.
As unlikely as that may be, she still holds
out hope.